außerhalb Tübingens bin ich entweder ein
Held oder ein Rassist sagt unser
heutiger gastüber sich selbst Boris
Palmer herzlich Willkommen zu Phoenix
persönlich danke für die Einladung Herr
Palmer sie sind in Tübingen vor einigen
Wochen zum dritten Mal in Folge mit
absoluter Mehrheit als Oberbürgermeister
wieder gewählt worden und das mit runder
Parteimitgliedschaft es gab Streitereien
um Rassismusvorwürfe und vermeintliche
Tabubrüche sie sind noch dazu gegen eine
grüne Gegenkandidatin angetreten und
haben im ersten Wahlgang schon über 50%
der Stimmen geholt wofür brauchen sie
eigentlich diese Parteien noch
vielleicht braucht die Partei mich ich
glaube das ist wichtig ist das Ökologie
Fürsprecher hat dass eine Partei auch in
der kommunalen Basis verankert ist dass
da Leute gibt die wissen wie man es
umsetzt Programme schreiben reicht nicht
und wir selber geht so dass ich Ökologie
für so wichtig haltet dass ich auf meine
herzenspartei nicht verzichten kann auch
wenn die sich für mich derzeit nicht in
die richtige Richtung entwickelt den
anderen Fragen bei Umweltfragen kommt es
auf die Grünen an und deswegen will ich
dabei bleiben dann haben sie natürlich
ihre Partei ich sag jetzt einfach
trotzdem mal weiter ihre Partei die
Mitgliedschaft gut ja nur in ein
gewisses Dilemma gestürzt könnte ich mir
vorstellen weil jemand der so
erfolgreich mit absoluter Mehrheit
wieder gewählt wird auf den möchte man
sicherlich auch auf Dauer in den Rhein
der Grünen nicht verzichten gibt es sind
da schon erste Annäherungsversuche
also ich habe mich sehr gefreut dass der
Ministerpräsident Wahlabend angerufen
hat das Robert habe ich mir gratuliert
hat das zeigt mir dass der das Band
nicht zerschnitten ist und jetzt gibt es
mal Gespräche mit der Landesvorsitzenden
und dann sehen wir wie es weitergeht
aber ich bin da in der Tat entspannt
denn es ist alles geregelt wenn wir
jetzt nichts tun dann geht einfach das
Jahr 23 rum und am 1.12 24 bin ich
wieder ganz ordentliches Mitglied nun
kam mir diese Runde Partei
Mitgliedschaft nicht von ungefähr der
Landesverband wollte sie sogar
ausschließen aus der Partei was würden
Sie denn sagen müssen Sie vielleicht in
den nächsten Monaten tun um wieder
salonfähig zu werden bei den Grünen das
liegt mir einfach nicht also diese
Anpassung um da Anpassung Willen bin ich
nicht dafür gemacht ich finde die Partei
würde gut daran tun sich zu fragen was
es bedeutet wenn die Stadt die
wahrscheinlich grüner ist als jede
andere in Deutschland wo die grüne
Kandidatin immer noch 22% kriegt wenn da
ruhend grüne die absolute Mehrheit holte
können Sie ausrechnen was übrig bleibt
für die anderen in so eine Stadt sagt
wir wollen dass der weitermacht da muss
man finde ich drüber nachdenken ob das
Ausschluss bemühen ob das richtig war
und nicht ob ich mich jetzt groß
verändern muss sie beklagen ja in ihrem
letzten Buch erst die Fakten dann die
Moral eine gewisse
realitätsfremde der Politik in Berlin
auch der Bundestagsabgeordneten und
sagen dass das in der Kommunalpolitik
ganz anders zugeht woran machen Sie das
fest
also erstens ist es logisch weil ich
nicht zu den Leuten gehen kann und sagen
das habe ich mir aber so ausgedacht und
jetzt findet es bitte gut sondern die
fragen mich funktioniert es oder
funktioniert nicht es liegt an oder ist
aus ganz einfach und
festmachen würde ich mal zwei
praktischen Beispielen die gerade immer
weiter verschärfte Erdbeben Norm nervt
mich weil sie dazu führt dass eine
Dachgaube auf einem Haus so gebaut
werden muss dass die stehen bleibt wenn
das Haus drunter wegen des Erdbebens
schon eingestürzt ist dafür habe ich
wenig Verständnis so machen wir aber
Normen in Deutschland und der gesunde
Menschenverstand sagt das ist keinen
Sinn das ist nur teuer und anderes
Beispiel ich muss mich damit rumschlagen
dass die Datenschutzbeauftragten gerade
in diesen Tagen wieder ein Papier
rausgegeben haben das Microsoft in
Deutschland von Behörden und Schulen
nicht verwendet werden sollen ich sage
Ihnen wir können schon wieder zurück in
die Kreidezeit aber es hat einfach
vollkommen sinnlos und wegen Datenschutz
Bedenken also bitte wollen es könnte
theoretisch sein dass Joe Biden meine
E-Mails lesen will und Microsoft zwingt
ihm diese Daten rauszugeben aber wissen
Sie was es würde mich freuen wenn dir
meine E-Mails das finde ich eine Ehre
der wird nämlich nichts finden was für
die USA sicherheitsrelevant ist und es
wird ihnen auch nicht interessieren und
solche verkopften weltfremden Konstrukte
die habe ich dauernd auf dem Tisch und
mein Job ist ganz häufig die klein zu
hacken und meinen Leuten zu sagen das
nehmen wir jetzt mal nicht so genau das
können die gar nicht gemeint haben und
da haben Sie das Gefühl die Berliner
Politik hat von sowas keine Ahnung oder
sie fühlen sich nicht unterstützt es
gibt ja auch Abgeordnete mit Wahlkreisen
beispielsweise ist leider schwieriger da
gibt es nämlich eine ungutes
Zusammenspiel zwischen dem Bürokratie
die immer nur auf ihr Fachgebiet guckt
und der egal ist was andere dann für
Nachteile haben und die immer schärfere
Standards wollen weil dafür sind die da
ist deren Lebensaufgabe und als
Abgeordneter wird man auch nicht
wirklich dadurch berühmt dass man
Gesetze zurücknimmt sondern wird auch
immer was Neues oben drauf gesagt noch
eine Wohltat irgendwas ganz tolles
erfunden was unser Geld kostet und Mühen
und Aufwand und dann gibt es noch die
Medien und die Gesellschaft die auch
immer mehr davon verlangen es wird eben
nicht verlangt jetzt lasst uns mal in
Ruhe mit den Vorschriften das gibt es
noch in den Sonntagsreden sondern Praxis
will jeder sofort dass das Problem jetzt
aber wirklich für alle Zeit durch eine
Regel beseitigt wird wenn er selber
davon betroffen ist und so eskalieren
wir uns zu einer Angstspirale immer
weiter in Regelungsdichte hinein die
niemand mehr bearbeiten können nun hat
das Land ja schwierige Wochen oder
Monate vielleicht sogar Jahre vor sich
durch die Energiekrise die Sorgen um
Inflation und so weiter wie gehen sie
denn jetzt konkret in Tübingen mit der
Energiekrise um die Wappen wenn sie ihre
Stadt
also wir haben schon mal vorgesorgt
indem die Stadtwerke Tübingen in den
letzten zehn Jahren den Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien an ihrer
Stromproduktion von drei auf 70%
ausgebaut haben wir werden nächstes Jahr
Richtung 80 Prozent gehen hätte
Deutschland auch so gehandelt hätten wir
gar kein echtes Problem haben wir leider
nicht gemacht wir sind nur ständig
ausgestiegen aber nirgends eingestiegen
den Fehler muss man dringend korrigieren
jetzt kurzfristig kann man gar nicht so
viel machen aber wir haben zumindest mal
entschieden Raumtemperaturen alle
öffentlichen Gebäuden runter auch da wo
ist der Bund nicht vorschreibt Schulen
zum Beispiel Kindergarten
Hallenbad Temperatur runter gibt
natürlich gleich Beschwerden drüber und
mittlerweile sind wir auch dazu
übergegangen nachts von 1 bis 5 Uhr die
Straßenbeleuchtung auszuschalten gibt
auch Beschwerden ich finde aber wenn man
Solidarität mit der Ukraine ernst nimmt
kann das nicht dabei aufhören nachts die
Straßenbeleuchtung mal abzustellen das
wiederum hat mich allerdings ein
bisschen gewundert weil sie haben ja in
ihrem letzten Buch auch ein Kapitel
geschrieben über das Schutzbedürfnis der
Bevölkerung über das Sicherheitsgefühl
dass sie da Verständnis zu haben dass
man diesen Gefühl entgegenkommt und
entsprechende Maßnahmen ergreift
zusätzlich wenn ich mir jetzt überlege
es geht ja nicht nur um arbeiten denn
die vor allen Dingen natürlich auch
Leute die in der Klinik arbeiten Leute
die Zeitung austragen Bäcker und so
weiter die Nacht schon unterwegs sind
sicherlich gibt es aber auch in Tübingen
eine Studenten statt viele junge
Menschen die lange jetzt nach der
corona-zeit nicht mehr ausgehen durften
die jetzt dann durch dunkle Straßen
gehen ich also Mutter einer Tochter
würde sagen das würde mich schon
Kreuzung glücklich machen wenn ich
wüsste diese Straßen sind Duster wie
gehen Sie damit um also erstmal gebe ich
Ihnen Recht für die Sicherheitsgefühl
der Menschen sind dunkle Straßen
schlecht aber wir wissen auch objektiv
verschlechtert sich die Sicherheit
dadurch allenfalls unmerklich es gibt
nicht mehr Verkehrsunfälle es gibt auch
nicht mehr Kriminalität kriminelle
brauchen zwar die Dunkelheit weil die
Menschen da schlafen aber nicht weil da
keine Beleuchtung ist das kriegen die
auch so hin und deswegen finde ich jetzt
ist eine neue Situation solange ich die
gefühlte Sicherheit nur sagen wir mal
gegen Stromkosten Abwege gewinnt die
gefühlte Sicherheit die ist dann
wichtiger aber wenn es jetzt um die
Gefahr eines drohenden Blackouts geht
und das ist die Argumentation die
Bundesregierung der ich da jetzt einfach
mal vertraue wir müssen Frankreichs
ausgefallene Atomreaktoren irgendwie
kompensieren dann dreht sich der
Argumentation um dann steht eine
gefühlte Gefahr gegen eine sehr große
Objektive Gefahr und dann muss ich die
Objektive Gefahr stärker gewichten
deswegen komme ich jetzt zum umgekehrten
Schluss und sage jetzt ist ausmachen
richtig trotzdem sind sie am Ende
verantwortlich wenn was passiert oder
man wird die verantwortlich machen lässt
sie das dann ruhig schlafen in der
dunklen Nacht oder denken Sie darüber
nach das lässt mich ruhig schlafen weil
ich weiß die Objektive Gefahr ist
faktisch nicht da da wird sich nichts
signifikant ändern und der Satz den sie
gerade gesagt haben verweist zurück auf
die Frage vorher das ist der ganz
typische Hammer wollen Sie dafür die
Verantwortung übernehmen dass und damit
wird in die nächste
Eskalationsstufe von Vorschriften immer
begründet und durch die Parlamente
gepeitscht weil alle sagen oh nein ich
will nicht die Verantwortung übernehmen
das und jetzt sieht sich hier und sage
ich ihnen jawohl ich will die
Verantwortung dafür übernehmen dafür bin
ich nämlich gewählt ich kann noch nicht
immer sagen ich will keine Verantwortung
ja sicher das muss ich in so einer
Krisensituation
Energiesparen funktioniert ja jetzt dann
zunehmend über all das sehen wir es hat
lange Zeit nicht funktioniert und treibt
vor allen Dingen junge Menschen immer
mehr auf die Straße wir haben in den
letzten Wochen fast täglich von den
Aktionen der sogenannten letzten
Generation gehört Kartoffelbrei auf
Kunstwerke letzte Woche haben sich sogar
geschafft zwei Stunden den Berliner
Flughafen lahmzulegen haben Sie
Verständnis für solche Proteste wie weit
dürfen die gehen
also ich habe Verständnis dafür dass
diese Menschen verzweifelt sind weil das
muss man einfach sagen meine Generation
hat es mit dem Klimaschutz grundlegend
versemmelt wir wussten alles und haben
fast nichts gemacht und es geht auf die
Kosten der nächsten Generation und dass
die dann aufmüpfig werden oder auch
verzweifelt sind weil sie meinen der
geht nichts voran das finde ich mehr als
verständlich das finde ich sogar gut
begründet was mich stört ist dass die zu
wenig darüber nachdenken was sie
bewirken und das ist der klassische Max
Weber Gesinnungsethik versus
Verantwortungsethik
gesinnungs-haft Friedrich Merz hat tolle
Presse dass er jetzt die Klima RAF
beschimpfen kann die ganze politische
Energie geht genau ins falsche und
deswegen würde ich die Leute einfach
bitten überlegt euch was ihr da tut
lasst uns doch gemeinsam was für den
Klimaschutz tun und jetzt nicht so eine
neue Schlacht aufmachen wo man nur
verlieren kann aber braucht das nicht
auch Aufsehen erregende Aktionen um
aufmerksam zu machen die jungen Menschen
haben mir das Gefühl dass sie sonst
keiner zur Kenntnis nimmt dass sie sich
nicht durchsetzen können und ich glaube
wenn ich so auf Ihren Lebenslauf schaue
so Aufsehen erregende Aktionen und
Protest und Demonstration für Dinge sind
sie ja durchaus auch eingestanden da
habe ich Sympathie für aber zwischen
aufsehenerregen und
blind beschädigen oder Gefahren für
andere in Kauf nehmen gibt's halt auch
noch einen Unterschied und ich kann
nicht erkennen was die Kunstwerke
verbrochen haben was das mit Klimaschutz
zu tun hat und ich kann auch nicht
einsehen warum es richtig sein soll mit
Bolzenschneider flughafensicherungen zu
durchdrehen wobei ich mir schon die
Frage stelle wenn die so einfach ist
schwer was könnte da noch alles
passieren ja aber vielleicht hat es auch
was Gutes und so weit aber da in Kauf zu
nehmen das vielleicht ein Flugzeug
nachher nicht landen kann und die
Notlandung machen muss im schlimmsten
Fall alles denkbar das geht mir einfach
zu weit
und sagen sie ja von sich dass sie der
Vertreter glasklarer grüner Werte sind
es gibt aber auch
tiefe Gräben in einigen anderen Feldern
die Sie wirklich trennen von der
Mehrheit würde ich jetzt mal denken der
Mitglieder ihrer Partei das ist zum
einen die Flüchtlingspolitik zum anderen
die sogenannte identitätsmobilität
Politik das ist vielleicht erstmal kurz
auf die Flüchtlingspolitik schauen sie
haben nach der flüchtlingskrise 2017 ein
Buch geschrieben mit dem Titel wir
können nicht allen helfen würden sie
jetzt in Bezug auf die Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine immerhin schon weit über
eine Millionen zwischen Deutschland das
so auch sagen ja stimmt ja
offensichtlich auch denn wir werden
wahrscheinlich nicht alle Ukraine in
Deutschland aufnehmen es wird
zahlenmäßig nicht geben von daher ist es
ja eine Binse sind einfach so viele
Menschen die Hilfe brauchen als dass wir
alle in Deutschland aufnehmen könnten
deswegen haben wir uns ja entschieden
mit Waffen zu helfen
damit die in ihrem Land eine eigene
Zukunft aufbauen können so bitter das
ist und es zeigt genau die dilemata auf
die ich mit dem Buch auch sonst
beschrieben habe das ist auch damals so
war dass der Gedanke man könne allen die
Hilfe gesucht haben in Deutschland durch
aufnahmehelfen falsch war und aus meiner
Sicht war eben noch falscher dass man
zugelassen hat ist die Hälfte derjenige
gekommen sind nach unserem Recht
keinerlei asylanspruch hatten dass wir
also die Hälfte die Hälfte der Hilfe gar
nicht den geleistet haben die sie am
aller trinkst nötig in hätte ich lieber
doppelt so viele Syrer aufgenommen als
die Hälfte aus starten die keinerlei
Fluchtgrund hatten aber es ist nicht
auch ein bisschen das Problem des
zungenschlags also natürlich jeder der
in den Nachrichten sieht Bürgermeister
Vertreter der Kommunen die sagen die
Turnhallen sind voll wir haben keinen
Platz mehr wir können keine Leute mehr
aufnehmen er hat zu nichts sicherlich
Verständnis dafür dass es einfach
erschöpft der Kapazitäten sind
wenn aber doch gleichzeitig der Satz
hinten dran käme wenn es nicht so wäre
wären Sie herzlich willkommen glauben
Sie nicht dass das in irgendeiner Form
in der Wahrnehmung etwas ändern würde
wir hören immer nur nein es geht nicht
ich glaube der zweite Satz würde
weggeschnitten wenn man dann die
Botschaft nicht mehr verbreiten könnte
also nein ja gerne ich sag's aber lieber
ein bisschen anders es geht nicht darum
dass man nachher noch ein empathischen
Satz hinterher ich sage immer von der
Empathie kann sich niemand was kaufen
das wird auch völlig überbewertet ist
doch egal ob ich jetzt als Mensch
Empathie da habe oder nicht wichtig ist
doch welche Entscheidungen ich treffe
sie können eh nicht rein gucken ob es
wahr ist oder gehäufelt meistens sind
die empathiebekundungen aus Prinzip
daher gesagt wenn man weiß dass es halt
erwartet wird bin ich auch nicht dafür
gemacht mir geht's lieber um die
Darstellung von echten Alternativen in
dem Fall wir können natürlich sehr viel
mehr Menschen aus der Ukraine aufnehmen
wenn wir die Standards absenken solange
aber eine Regelung gilt dass die ihn
Rechtsanspruch auf den Kindergartenplatz
haben wie jedes Kind das hier geboren
wurde und Schulbildung und Wohnung
bekommen sollen muss ich sagen da sind
wir jetzt ein Grenzen ange angekommen
wurde es nicht mehr erreichbar ist weil
ich die Menschen nicht habe weil die
Wohnungen nicht da sind und wenn wir
bereit wären zu sagen okay
die kommenden Turnhallen was anders geht
gerade nicht mehr da werden Zeltstädte
aufgebaut was anderes geht gerade nicht
mehr die kommen nicht mehr in Kitas
sondern die müssen ihre Kinder in den
Spielgruppen selbst betreuen dann könnt
ihr mir natürlich sehr viel mehr
aufnehmen und da vor sich zu drücken und
so zu tun als ginge es mit den jetzigen
Standards beliebig viele aufzunehmen das
finde ich nicht redlich wenn man sich
dann vor dem Problem dass die vor uns
auf der kommunalen Ebene gelöst werden
muss einfach herum drückt
hat man die Leute denn vielleicht
einfach mal gefragt also keine Ahnung
ich stelle mir jetzt vor wenn ich eine
Mutter wäre aus der Ukraine und ich
hätte kleine Kinder und ich würde
sowieso in zwei oder drei Monaten wieder
zurückgehen wollen dann würde ich ja gar
nicht durchsetzen wollen das meine
Kinder jetzt unbedingt in diese Kita
kommen sondern wahrscheinlich wäre ich
froh wenn sie gut und und und warmherzig
betreut werden das heißt wenn wir immer
sagen die haben aber Anspruch auf das
und das und das deshalb geht es nicht
man könnte sie ja auch Fragen klar wenn
Sie den Anspruch äußern haben sie den
aber geht man denn überhaupt ins
Gespräch vor Ort schaut man sowas oder
macht man es einfach nur an Zahlen fest
und an Regeln und sagt Regeln wie sie
gerade selber beklagt haben dass sie sie
gibt das ist aber so und so und deshalb
ist sie muss jetzt hier Schluss sein
genau wir werden in der Verwaltung in
Tübingen versuchen solche Spielgruppen
aufzubauen weil wir die Plätze einfach
nicht haben wenn dann noch mehr Kinder
kommen heißt es entweder diese Kinder
bekommen keinen Platz oder ein Kind von
Tübinger Eltern bekommen keinen Platz
und aus dem Dilemma komme ich nicht mehr
raus es gibt keine Menschen die ich
einstellen könnte dafür die
Erziehungsstellen der Markt ist komplett
leer und dann sage ich lieber versuchen
wir doch im Einvernehmen mit den
ukrainischen Menschen Spielgruppen
aufzubauen als dass ich dieses Dilemma
einfach so stehen lassen und sagen naja
gut wer kein Platz kriegt hat halt Pech
gehabt das wäre sozusagen Business usual
wenn ich nur auf die Rechtslage gucken
müsste ich so machen dafür bin ich aber
nicht gewählt ich muss gucken dass die
Probleme vor Ort gelöst werden dann weiß
ich lieber von der Vorgabe ab nun haben
wir gerade in diesen Tagen wieder viel
von Fachkräftemangel demografischen
Wandel dass wir viel viel mehr
Zuwanderung bräuchten Einwanderung was
ist denn vor diesem Hintergrund davon zu
halten eigentlich müssten wir uns doch
für jeden Freunde kommen im Moment
also das stimmt für die Menschen aus der
Ukraine stärker als es für die
2015/16 geflüchteten menschengilde habe
ich in Tübingen aktuelle Zahlen die
sagen dass gerade mal ein Viertel der
arbeitsfähigen voll erwerbsfähig
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftige
ich nach sechs bis sieben Jahren wenn
ich mal kurz einhaken darf ja aber da
ist es natürlich vor allen Dingen auch
ein Problem der Sprache und so weiter
könnte man direkt fragen müsste man dann
nicht mehr für die Sprachausbildung tun
man kann immer fragen was wir noch
hätten machen müssen ich will dich jetzt
gar nicht im Einzel auseinander pflegen
ich glaube wir müssen vor allem mehr
verlangen weil diese Menschen sich dran
gewöhnt haben dass es nicht viel von
ihnen verlangt wird wäre nämlich was
verlangt ist Rassist und lässt es dann
schnell bleiben aber jenseits dieser
These und das Rückblicks sage ich da
gibt es einen Unterschied die
ukrainischen Menschen sind sicherlich
sehr viel qualifiziert und geeigneter
für unseren Arbeitsmarkt als die
Menschen die vor sieben Jahren gekommen
sind soweit ja aber es steht heute was
anderes dagegen nämlich das
Überlebensinteresse der Ukraine wir
sollten eigentlich nicht darauf abzielen
diese Menschen alle dauerhaft bei uns in
den Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen sondern
unser Ziel muss doch alle aller
unterziehen muss doch sein in die
Rückkehr in Irland zu ermöglichen und
das heißt nicht dass sie jetzt nicht
arbeiten sollten aber darauf unsere
eigene Arbeitsmarktpolitik aufzubauen
ist eigentlich doch gegenüber der
Ukraine recht unsolidarisch trotzdem
wenn wir beim Arbeitsmarkt bleiben
geschätzt werden 400.000 die Leute im
Jahr benötigt hat zumindest Frau Nahles
ausgerechnet die pro Jahr zuwandern
müssen wir diskutieren im Moment auch
über das neue einbürgerungsgesetz die
Ampelkoalition möchte dass man schon
noch fünf Jahren einen Pass bekommen
kann
Opposition sagt wir veramischen den
deutschen Pass außerdem geht um die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft wo auch Herr
März gerade heute wieder gesagt hat wir
verbessern die Loyalität zu Deutschland
wenn wir das zu einfach machen dass man
mehrere Pässe hat wie wie schauen Sie
auf diese Debatte wie immer pragmatisch
da habe ich auch vor Jahren mit meinem
cdu-kollegen aus Schwäbisch Gmünd eine
Forderung formuliert die heißt doppelter
Spurwechsel und die sagt lasst alle die
hier arbeiten die unsere Sprache
leidlich lernen und nicht mit dem
gesetzlichen Konflikt kommen lass die
hier Aufenthaltstitel und danach fünf
Jahren auch die Staatsbürgerschaft unter
diesen Bedingungen warum denn nicht sie
werden nicht gehen und wir dürfen sie
auch gar nicht gehen lassen aber
andererseits und der zweite Teil fehlt
mir dann oft bei denen die dieses
fordern finde ich auch dass es mehr
Konsequenz braucht bei der Abschiebung
von Straftätern und Menschen die sich
halt nicht in unsere Gesellschaft
einfügen und die gibt es da kann man
auch nicht wegschauen unter den
Asylbewerbern eben auch und es ist halt
das linke Dogma das eine Problem nicht
zu sehen und das rechte dog mal das
andere Problem mich zu sehen meine
kommunalpolitische Sicht ist beide
Probleme gemeinsam sehen und gemeinsam
lösen dann bleiben wir mal bei den
beiden Problemen und gehen zum nächsten
Thema wenn es für sie okay ist und zwar
so eine sogenannten wirken
Identitätspolitik Burg steht ja zunächst
mal für Wache aufmerksam sein gegen
Diskriminierung was haben sie da dagegen
dagegen habe ich nichts wer könnte der
Rest der Gegner
sie beklagen aber doch dass sie sich
zunächst irgendwie schon sehr
indoktriniert fühlen von dieser
sogenannten wirken Bewegung dass sie
sich bevormundet fühlen und so weiter
vielleicht erklären Sie es noch mal kurz
ja geht mir nicht um die Ziele sondern
um die Methoden
wenn man sich schon selber für erwacht
hält also die anderen irgendwie im
Schlaf Zustand weint dann ist ganz
automatisch die Gefahr da dass man die
Wahrheit für sich alleine beansprucht
und Regie die Methoden anwendet um
durchzusetzen und genau das erlebe ich
das nicht mehr versucht wird durch die
besseren Argumente zu überzeugen sondern
dass durch Denunziation und
Diskreditierung andere Auffassungen
diese abweichenden Meinungen und zum
Schweigen gebracht werden sollen und
nebenbei ich sehe dieses
Parteiausschlussverfahren dieses
missliche und gescheiterte in dieser
unguten Tradition begründet ist genau
der Versuch eine abweichende Stimme
nicht mehr hören zu wollen und das ist
dieser Wolkenbewegung leider in die
Genetik geschrieben und muss bei aller
Unterstützung der Ziele einfach klar
formuliert sein aber sie räumen doch ein
dass es zum Teil doch Minderheiten sind
die lange Zeit nicht zu ihrem Recht
gekommen sind oder absolut wäre es dann
nicht angebracht wenn man diese Rechte
jetzt mehr in den Vordergrund stellen
würde kommen ja jetzt gar nicht mit dem
sie sind kein älterer weißer Mann
sondern vielleicht ein Mittelalter
weißer Mann aber ich meine wie lange
sind die Vorteile irgendwie gerade von
diesen sogenannten älteren weißen
Männern wirklich gepflegt worden wir
erinnern uns an dieses wunderbare Bild
aus Davos wo wirklich führende
Wirtschaft führende Politik es waren
alles nur Männer wäre es dann nicht
angebracht dass jetzt die anderen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen nicht nur
prozentual gesehen zu ihrem Recht kommen
sondern eben gerade um um zu Beton hey
ihr wart wirklich benachteiligt müssen
wir sind ja nicht gerade irgendwie jetzt
durchaus ein bisschen hervorheben machen
sie da vielleicht nicht doch ein
bisschen mehr zu sagen das halte ich für
ein Irrtum ich bin ganz klar dafür dass
jede Form der Diskriminierung beendet
werden muss und dafür muss es auch
staatliche Maßnahmen geben was es nicht
geben darf ist eine neue Diskriminierung
nämlich von Leistung Eignung und
Befähigung derjenigen die Herr
dummerweise zu den gehören die über sich
Jahrzehnte bevorzugt waren
Benachteiligungen neue benachteil sind
keine Verbesserung einer Gesellschaft
und genau das passiert man überdreht
also das Prinzip und anstelle der
Gleichheit aller als Ziel wird jetzt die
Bevorzugung bisher benachteiligter zu
Maxime erhoben und das Denkfehler dabei
und meiner Meinung nach sogar
grundgesetzwidrig sah ich ganz klar denn
das Grundgesetz hält zum Beispiel fest
dass öffentliche Ämter nach Leistung
Eignung und Befähigung zu vergeben sind
da steht nicht Hautfarbe sexuelle
Orientierung oder benachteiligungsstatus
Schutz von Minderheiten
selbstverständlich vor Benachteiligung
aber nicht von Schutz von Minderheiten
durch bevorzugen das ist einfach das Rad
eine Runde zu weit gedreht sie beklagen
des Weiteren es gäbe eine deutliche
Grenze das Sagbaren in Deutschland was
wo ist denn die Grenze für Sie und haben
Sie das Gefühl dass sie sie auch schon
mal verletzt haben
also es gibt einerseits Leute die die
Grenze immer weiter verschieben wollen
die Vororte ich mal überwiegend bei der
AFD die wollen jede Form des Rassismus
und der Diskriminierung wieder hochfähig
machen dagegen muss man sich natürlich
entschieden so wie ersetzen durch
übrigens auch als direkt Betroffener ich
habe jüdische Vorfahren und manches was
daran Antisemitismus ausgekippt wird ist
einfach unerträglich aber auf der
anderen Seite ist es eben auch falsch
wenn der Korridor gesagt waren immer
weiter eingeengt werden soll wenn zum
Beispiel die Moorenstraße in Berlin weg
muss obwohl begriffsgeschichtlich daran
einfach nichts auszusetzen ist und von
einem strukturellen Rassismus die Rede
ist der ihnen mir unterstellt dass wir
Urteils unfähig sind und gar nicht
mitreden können in Fragen die people of
color betrachten
herumgeistert wenn man sich dagegen
stellt und diese moderne Ideologie
kritisiert dann wird die die
vermehrungsmaschine angeworfen dann
kommt der Shitstorm da können sich
darauf verlassen und wenn man nur fragt
wie ich es gemacht habe ist es
eigentlich angemessen dass die Werbung
der Deutschen Bahn nur noch Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund zeigt wie das in
einem Bild der Fall gewesen ist
ausschließlich Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund was soll uns das
sagen ist es die Gesellschaft in der wir
leben ist es nicht denn es gibt noch 80
Prozent 70 Prozent je nachdem wo sie
sind in welcher Generation Menschen die
keinen Migrationshintergrund haben ich
habe keinen und ich finde es nicht
richtig wie die dann gar nicht mehr
vorkommen wenn das schon genügt dass sie
bundesweit da als Rassist verschrien
werden dann wird eben versucht den
Korridor gesagt waren über das
notwendige Maß hinaus einzugehen dagegen
wäre ich mich so ein bisschen auch aus
Leidenschaft heraus da bin ich
schwäbischer Dickschädel ich lass mir
nicht vorschreiben was ich schwätze darf
viele werfen ihn ja vor dass sie zu
temperamentvoll sind auch zu impulsiv
selbst die enger Freund Rätsel Schlauch
hat neulich gesagt vielleicht sollten
sie ein wenig an ihre impuls-kontrolle
Arbeiten
habe ich auch gemacht oh ja erzählen sie
wo waren da also er hat gesagt ich
verteidige dich nur wenn du bei deinem
Facebook jetzt da mal langsamer machst
habe ich gemacht langsamer
Begriff
rückblickend
das nach würden Sie sagen sie haben
irgendwo vielleicht auch Fehler gemacht
die waren nämlich aus auch bereit sich
zu entschuldigen muss man natürlich auch
sagen aber gibt es Dinge wo sie sagen
Mensch das beschäftigt mich noch das
hätte ich nicht machen sollen nein das
beschäftigt mich nicht also sich mit der
Vergangenheit die man nicht ändern kann
dauerhaft zu beschäftigen bringt ja
bekanntlich nichts aber es gibt Dinge
die ich trotzdem rückblickend für
fehlerhalte und anders machen würde der
Anlass für das Verfahren weil jetzt
wirklich eine Dummheit ich hätte es
dabei belassen sollen Denis Aogo gegen
diese wie ich finde vollkommen und
unsägliche Entscheidung in vom
Bildschirm zu löschen nur weil er gesagt
hat die trainieren bis zum vergasen ist
zum Beispiel für eine unnötige eininn
von Juden zu tun er wird auf dem
Sportplatz oft gesagt da muss doch einer
nicht vom Bildschirm verschwinden wenn
er das mal nebenbei da kommentiert
dagegen habe ich ihn verteidigt dabei
hätte ich es belassen sollen und nicht
dann in einem nachhol-gefegt diesen
besser nicht zitierbaren Satz über
wie sagt man so schön ja also
ein Wort ja dass das inwort in
Verbindung mit einem sexuell anzüglichen
Begriff zu benutzen das war halt eine
Dummheit
viele schauen ja wenn sie auf ihre Vita
schauen auch auf ihren Vater der ja ein
großer Widerspruchsgeist war und viel
gegen viele Dinge protestiert hat er hat
allein 250 Mal versucht Bürgermeister zu
werden leider erfolglos sie jetzt zum
dritten Mal in Folge mit absoluter
Mehrheit haben Sie das Gefühl dass da
auch so eine Art familiäre Wunde jetzt
heilen kann
es ist ja schon 18 Jahre tot also das
Gefühl habe ich nicht aber ich denke
manchmal wenn er da oben zuguckt ob er
jetzt ausnahmsweise mal nicht brudle
Date weil das war eher so seine
Regelkommunikation brudler schimpfen ja
das war prudelt halt und es war eben
nicht so gegeben den Sohn zu loben
vielleicht würde er jetzt doch so ein
lächelnder Anerkennung über die Lippen
bringen wo sehen Sie denn den späten
Boris Palma er in der altersmilde oder
im Altersstar sind
oh ich fürchte den altersstars hin ich
weiß dass er eine echte Gefahr ist und
hoffe ihn zu vermeiden aber sicher bin
ich nicht
Boris Palmer vielen Dank für das
Gespräch
[Musik]